foreign
[Music]
this is Star Talk Cosmic queries Edition
grab bag Chuck that's your favorite
category isn't it gotta love the grad
Bag Man
all kinds of good stuff up in the grab
bag you just reach them at us with
whatever they want you put your hand and
you don't know what you're gonna pull
out and there it is right
all right let's get right to it it's
it's Star Talk Bingo
and it's all uh patreon members five
dollars a month get your access all
right best deal in town waste no time no
time with jumping right into a Kate from
Warsaw Poland says hello Dr Tyson Hello
Lord nice lately I've been wondering
about the Fermi Paradox do you think it
could be possible we have found no
Advanced civilizations or have not been
found because of the speed of light
could they just be too far away or could
it be that they have done to their
planets what we are currently doing to
ours and they're just all dead okay all
right so let me remind people about the
Fermi Paradox uh Enrico Fermi it was an
Italian-American physicist uh in 20th
century physicist a brilliant guy and he
did an actual calculation on the back of
an envelope as we we call it so it
wasn't some Grand chalkboard calculation
just he made some estimates and he said
all right I know the speed of light is
fast but let's say they have a
civilization that can go maybe
one-fifth the speed of light some
fraction of this 10 percent the speed of
light I'm not is that asking too much
all right too much that's not too much
all right but let's say 10 the speed of
light
how long would it take you to cross the
Galaxy the Galaxy is a hundred thousand
light years across
so if you go ten percent the speed right
it'll take you 10 times that it'll take
you a million years all right that
sounds long but hang on a minute that's
not where you're first going to go
you're going to go from our star system
to the nearby star system okay okay and
then you're going to pitch tent growth
civilization and now you're going to
launch again and then but now you're
gonna not just gonna go to one more
you're gonna go to two more okay okay
and then each of those two will go to
two more each that goes to four
to 8 to 16 and so your civilization
spreads out
rapidly exponentially
all right and you'll get to nearby stars
in 10 20 30 50 years all right and you
just have a new civilization there and
they send out two more two more probes
what he concluded was
if any sensible assumptions you make
the whole galaxy and all available
planets can be colonized within a few
million years
okay that is short compared with the
lifetime of the Galaxy
so if it's nothing so would Johnny come
lately here suppose you had an advanced
civilization that started five billion
years ago at the birth of the Sun a
whole other star that's been around all
right then they could be all over the
Galaxy and we don't see them
okay so then everyone is saying well how
come we don't see them yes one of the
reasons are they could be just like us
and destroy their own Planet okay
they're so smart they figured out how to
destroy themselves that's one example uh
another one is
space travel is just too hard it's just
hard
to move around to your moon they're
stupid
God this is hard
no one told us
yeah we keep trying to go to space and
we can't it's just hard okay
that's crazy weeping aliens across the
couch exactly can't do it so
um
all right so that so that's what one of
the reasons another one uh this is my
favorite of them is that whatever
genetic profile whether or not they use
genes whatever is in you that wants you
to colonize planets
if that's driving your entire
civilization and and you go this way and
you get two planets and you get two
planets there'll come a time
where we both want the same Planet
exactly who why why did why do they have
why is their Planet so much nicer in our
planet we all started at the same time I
don't understand it why is there Planet
so much better
you know what we should do you know no
I'm just saying guys what we should do
we should go over there and take that
play
we should take that plan okay let's now
wait a minute just this colonization in
a nutshell yeah there you go now now
listen just because we're on planet
caucasoid and they're on planet negro
doesn't mean that we're doing it just
because of that
all right so if that's the case then the
the whole system will implode which kind
of happened with European colonists all
right England had colonies France had
colonies Spain had colonies Portuguese
Portugal that colonies the Dutch head
colonies and you reach a point where
there's not enough land to go around and
they fight each other for control of
that land okay so we saw that play out
on Earth's surface
where if you have this expansionist
mentality so it could be that whatever
is the urge that would want to make that
happen in the first place has the seeds
of its own unraveling
wow so the the the Curiosity that brings
you to want to Branch out yeah and the
drive more important yes
is the thing that is your undoing yeah
because that same Drive caused you to
Lust For The Very things that you want
to achieve
and others
I'm the only person that can have this
right right I want to do this and I
wouldn't call it curiosity so much as
hegemony oh yeah great word
I'm lucky are you hegeminist you know
yeah the need to to conquer and to
exactly to control this is a this is a
thing but
third category or fourth I lost track
this is my favorite you ready
um they have come to Earth
and they tried to visit and they saw all
of the space debris orbiting Earth and
they said no they were like that's
Sanford and Son Planet that's the
Sanford and Son Planet oh you're saying
you're saying those aliens are black
they say um
look at all that junk in their front
yard nobody would have come see that why
would we want to go there so there's
that boy I got another one right so I
take full credit for this one they have
visited
but they accidentally landed during
Comic-Con
yeah okay okay
nobody noticed that is so silly but it's
so funny
they're like listen we kept saying take
me to your leader people would laugh at
us it's a good one good one and love the
costume and then they would walk away
from us what is what's wrong with some
people what's up with that yeah yeah
yeah so I think that one I I that's the
most fun one for me to think about I
think or or they rather than destroy us
which is every movie wants them to do
they they phoned home and said on Earth
they're just like us
oh yeah nothing interesting yeah nothing
to see here yeah so those are the
Prevailing uh there might be others
those are the ones I carry with me for
solutions to the Fermi Paradox why
they're not here yeah awesome all right
let's go to Omar Marcelino and ulmar
says
um
hello Dr Tyson and Chuck Omar here
originally from the boogie down Bronx oh
Bronx in the house living in Texas now
my son Roman who was seven wants to know
this from you Dr Tyson if you had a
chance to see only one
would you rather see dinosaurs live and
roaming the planet
or aliens
so I'm gonna have to pick aliens only
because even though I love me some
dinosaurs we already have pretty good
representations of them in movies we got
their fossil bones we've got good
archaeological evidence and so I I'm
aliens totally aliens yeah yeah that
definitely and if it asks me to take it
to our leader I ain't taking it to the
White House I'm sorry
I'm gonna go I might go to Washington
where the National Academy of Sciences
meets and that's cool bring them to a
meeting yeah I would take them to
Beyonce
[Laughter]
that'll mess with his head I don't know
all right next question
this is Brendan gambasi or gambouche he
gave me helping you out
helping you out okay helping me out
gambouche from Lansing Michigan Michigan
he says you can't pronounce Michigan
I got the guy's name finally right and
then I messed up the state isn't that
something okay
I miss you all right
okay he says hello Dr Tyson I am
interested in knowing what your favorite
astronomical discovery of all time is
and Lord nice what is your favorite
thing that you've learned on starch
I love that I love it that's hilarious I
love it so my favorite is the fact
that
the discovery that we all life on Earth
and Earth itself
owes its chemical Origins
to stars that have exploded after having
manufactured them in its core
the exploded scattering that enrichment
across the Galaxy reaching pristine gas
clouds that would form a next generation
of stars and planets one of which was
ours
that Discovery was in 1957 in a research
paper by four authors one one of them is
a couple that were married Burbage
Burbage Fowler and Hoyle and that is the
basically the origin of the elements
it's a spiritual gift of modern
astrophysics to civilization for us to
now be able to tell you we are not just
figuratively so we are literally
Stardust wow and not only
that as we are alive in this universe
because we contain Stardust the universe
is alive within us
then
is my favorite astronomical discovery
nice all right so Chuck what's your
favorite thing you've learned oh what I
just learned right here
[Laughter]
no everything is my favorite thing that
I've learned really I oh God yes I tell
people all the time that my job is to
take a master class in astrophysics with
the world's foremost science
communicator and uh like like who could
have a better job than that whoa that's
amazing okay so you you want a diploma
or something you're [__] for a
certificate of completion you know it'd
be kind of cool if I could get a little
certificate
Chuck is not the stupidest thing okay
uh very cool all right we gotta take a
break we're gonna take a quick break
when we come back more
more StarTalk Cosmic queries grab bag
Edition when we return
all right Chuck let's keep this going
all right the party going just keep the
ball of wax rolling here we go this is
Matt Berg he says wait wait read it
keeps a ball of wax rolling what what
yeah what balls of wax roll what what
what does that come from
what is that
it's just something that comedians used
to say when they were uh MC shows all
right guys let's keep this bottle of wax
rolling it's not a thing that wax does
well then any ball would roll it just
have to be waxed
okay fine go on all right this is uh
Matt Burke he says greetings Dr Tyson
Lord nice Matt Berg here from ship Boy
again Falls Middle School in Wisconsin
middle school middle school middle
school yes sir buddy uh he says one of
the main Concepts we discussed in my
middle school class is the importance of
basing final conclusions on scientific
evidence that is gathered a student and
I were talking about the expansion of
the universe and she asked that if the
universe is expanding faster than the
speed of light doesn't that in essence
make part of the universe essentially
inaccessible just as our seeing inside a
black hole is impossible thereby
prohibiting us from ever Gathering the
needed information to make a final
conclusion especially back to the
original Singularity if I understand
this correctly and this is indeed true
the fact the fact that we are losing
access to the evidence makes me feel
very very uneasy could you please please
make me feel better by telling me that
I'm wrong
help me
we don't know what he had all that
emotion at the end of the letter I took
a little liberty
a poetic license by the way it's three
quarters of the way through that we did
not know whether that person was a
student or a teacher no we didn't we
didn't I said damn if a middle school
student is asking this yeah if a middle
school student was asking right right
okay so
um everything uh tell me the person's
name again this is Matt Berg Matt Berg
Matt everything Matt says is correct
yeah we are losing we are losing the
universe as it expands beyond our
Horizon
and in the limit if the acceleration of
the expansion continues then every
single galaxy in the night sky
will expand beyond our visible Horizon
leaving our galaxy and the Stars within
it alone in our own observable universe
look at that yes so an island Galaxy an
island Galaxy and as far as we would
know an island Universe why would there
be anything else in fact that's what we
used to think we used to think all the
galaxies were just fuzzy little things
within the Milky Way and Hubble says
whoa these fuzzy things are flying away
they can't be within our own Galaxy
they're other galaxies
if the day that comes where all the
galaxies have expanded beyond our
Horizon we will return to what we
thought the universe was like before
Hubble
just our own Galaxy and that's it so
yeah it's where the Galaxy is thinning
out get over it look at that just like
your hair Matt
these are just the harsh realities of
life my friend
all right all right
this is Jesse McIntyre and Jesse says
Hey nunchuck and Dr Tyson he called you
nunchuck he called me nunchuck chuck all
right I guess I'm gotta get ready to get
flung around by Bruce Lee yeah you're a
martial arts weapon yeah all right yes
it's Jesse the farmer from Duvall
Washington here regarding quantum
entanglement if information is
instantaneous regardless of distance is
the bridge between the two particles
possibly and Einstein rosenbridge well
anyway love the show and get learned yes
boom
and and just to bring closure to that uh
I think I mentioned this in another
episode I was having lunch with Brian
Greene and author of The Elegant
universe and and several other books
that followed that and a brilliant
educator found co-founder with his wife
of the world Science Festival held
annually in New York and
uh so the what he told me was these in
the vacuum of space we've known that
through these things called virtual
particles because quantum physics says
you can't have zero energy anywhere that
there's fluctuations in the space-time
fabric Quantum fluctuations that will
always give you a little bit of energy
you'll never be pure zero people there
are people who want to tap that vacuum
energy and like Propel themselves with
it we don't know how to do that yet or
if ever but point is these virtual
particles pop in and out of existence
from that energy equals mc squared then
they come back together again okay so
when they pop into existence
they are quantum entangled and then they
return no longer Quantum entangled
there's been some thinking lately to
suggest that
these two Quantum entangle particles are
connected by a wormhole such as the the
the EP bridge that he mentioned that's a
wormhole okay right it's just a fancier
name for a wormhole that's your name so
if that's the case
and these particles are happening
everywhere it may be that wormholes are
themselves
the fabric that Stitches the space-time
Continuum oh look at that that the that
the wormholes that connect entangle
particles
is the medium of the space-time
Continuum and that's a profound new
thought that's that's my new thought for
the month yes that's amazing yes that's
crazy by the way crazy it's crazy it's
crazy it had to be stitched somehow
somebody's got to do this
it's the wormholes
amazing that is fantastic yeah oh I'm so
glad you asked that question Jesse
McIntyre that's all right farmer what
kind of Farmers
Washington is growing apples or grapes
one or the other uh true so for
stereotype very good Pinos right or yes
yes yeah Oregon Oregon Washington Pinos
yeah and Chardonnay as well yeah yeah
very cool all right
um this is Colin Brum and Colin says my
first query ever guys
um he says this one's kind of been
annoying at me regardless regarding
black holes how can matter fall into the
singularity or even past the Event
Horizon at all if someone approaching
the Event Horizon would see for the
first time the rest of the universe
speed up infinitely and black holes
don't last for an infinite time due to
the Hawking radiation shouldn't any
martyr matter Falling Towards The Event
Horizon either be instantly turned into
Hawking radiation in its own time frame
or simply Ride The Event Horizon down as
the black hole evaporates away neither
one of these would allow you to go to
the singularity which is something
physics can't currently explain any way
love listening to you guys keep up with
this incredible show and who asked this
question
this is Colin Brum okay Colin Brum Chuck
gave you attitude for the end of that
question
which physics can't explain anyway
anyway well you know there's I see these
kind of like comments sometimes where
people I'm just saying nobody gave you
permission to give attitude to the
questions I know a lot of people think
that the singularity is a BS concept
well we don't know I think it's cheating
they think it's cheating no it's the
edge of Einstein's general theory of
relativity and we need another theory to
extend it so right so it's not cheating
it's just it's our ignorance just there
you go right we're very candid about it
all right I love that right you can be
ignorant of something and go to the edge
of knowledge but then you just say I'm
at the edge of knowledge yes we need
something else here yeah because if we
step over this line doesn't I'm sorry
stuff does not work out anymore yeah so
we need something else I think that
brilliant that's one of the things I
love most about every time we do this
show and just and it's occasionally said
that the singularity of a black hole is
where God divided by zero all right
remember you're not supposed to divide
by zero you can't divide by zero zero
don't don't do that
so here's the thing if you fall towards
a black hole you're just going to fall
in right you don't stop anywhere you
just keep going if we try to watch you
fall in that's a different story okay so
but you you're you and your time frame
time is ticking just like normal for you
so no you're not held up but as you
cross the Event Horizon and you go down
towards the center of the black hole you
will see the entire future history of
the universe unfold before you
right and if you don't come out the
other side uh an interesting question is
there you will get Hawking radiated
uh-huh while you're watching the future
history of the universe play out
right that can't be comfortable
yeah I don't know which words the
spaghettification falling in or the
Hawking radiation Adam by Adam as you
come out yeah
so yeah so it's all about
frame of reference yes yes it's all
about frame of reference yes yes so you
got if you try to look at it like you're
not without the frame of reference then
you're screwing the whole thing right
exactly you're combining your cross
combining frames of reference and you
can't do that it doesn't work out you
don't get a coherent understanding of
what's going on
there you go okay fantastic all right
here we go now this is Dre odd menko
Drake ottomenko he says a mirror shows a
reflection of whatever is in front of it
what does it reflect if we put a second
identical mirror directly in front of it
with 100 precision
we've all seen the infinite tunnel of
mirrors in the public bathrooms when
they're facing each other but it's
impossible to look directly at the
center because the object or the person
is in the way what would we see at the
center Darkness avoid a parallel
universe
this is really bending my mind man
okay if if Who's the who asked this
again this is Dre aramenco Dre if you
manage to do this it will create a rip
in the space-time fabric of the universe
so I don't recommend it you will destroy
us all Trey that's what will happen
um
so what would be there so I let me just
think this through I haven't thought
about this before so if they're exactly
front and back there'll be some light
that comes in from the side but that'll
reflect off to the other side okay and
it won't go in line with the mirrors if
they're exactly facing each other
and there's no light
in that path then it should just be
completely dark with nothing to reflect
ruining your fun house mirror phenomenon
it just would just go dark as it already
is if you look at the multiple mirror
Reflections the farther in the mirror
you see the dimmer it gets then did
America gets that's right that's correct
because it has less light to to reflect
back and forth black all that many times
so it gets darker and darker and darker
but in this case there's no reason why
it wouldn't just be dark right off the
top right off the top because there's no
light there there you go now I've never
done the experiment but using my
knowledge of Reflections and physics
that would be my answer
super cool yeah yeah it'd be cool to see
you know so what you might do is get a
two-way mirror okay and then put maybe
put a laser through you know when it
comes through and you'll still get a
reflection see what happens I don't know
okay there you go
so there's your homework okay
got a little homework to do buddy yeah
all right here we go this is pioter
tarnowski okay toransky I think so okay
you know and it's peorter from Poland so
maybe it's just maybe that's Polish ways
to impedance I'm not sure okay I'm gonna
call I'm gonna call you Peter okay okay
he says hey Dr Tyson what's up Chuck uh
my question concerns the shape of the
universe if we know that the universe is
ever expanding does that mean it has an
edge if the Big Bang happened in all
places at once does maybe then the
universe keep expanding more like a ball
so without a clear Edge if so would that
ball be in some higher Dimension thanks
and love the show Peter or pioter from
Poland yeah yeah so
Peter is is Polish for Peter right oh it
is I'm pretty sure that right all right
so uh so excellent question so first of
all uh with the universe when we give
speak of its size it's to the our
Horizon now that edge is today farther
away than that because it's been
expanding for 14 billion years since
then okay so if you look at the actual
diameter of the full Universe it's not
an observable diameter but you can
calculate it last I checked it was
something like 90 to 94 billion miles in
diameter all right the universe today
Beyond the Horizon there's no reason to
think there isn't more Universe more
Universe yeah just like a ship at Sea
there's probably more ocean just beyond
your horizon okay eventually you hit
land great but until then you're not
saying all I can see is the entire ocean
no one is saying that all right right so
now the question was
uh what's outside of that the expansion
well we don't know for sure but the
Multiverse
which is what you get for free when you
bring quantum physics to general
relativity and Einstein you get a
Multiverse that's pumping out universes
and there are different levels of
Multiverse but the simplest
is that it's outside of our Horizon
there are other bubbles of universes
so that doesn't require a higher
Dimension to embed them
it's just just imagine uh how would you
do this
um a a big rubber expanding rubber sheet
but you have these circles that you draw
and each circle in that circle is an
expanding Circle that's a universe and
then another Universe over here so the
space time wouldn't enclose multiple
universes that are expanding that can
happen too
um but there are higher level
multiverses that inquire require
embedding in higher dimensions and you
can do that you can have infinite
universes that don't overlap
you know how to do that did I tell you
how to do that you watch Rick and Morty
yes that's how you do that no no so
let's take it take it down a few
Dimensions so let's say the universe is
a flat sheet of paper okay okay two
Dimensions instead of three spatial
Dimensions make that sheet of paper
infinitely large
okay now take another sheet of paper
put it above it and make that infinitely
large we have two infinite sheets of
paper that do not intersect
right
they don't touch each other so because
they're embedded in a higher Dimension
they're two-dimensional objects they are
literally parallel universes oh there
you go so we take our universe and embed
it in a higher Dimension we could be
infinite sitting right next to another
infinite universe and never the twain
would meet
that being said there are people who are
looking for universes That Go Bump in
the night
is there a signature in our universe in
this direction
that looks a little different from this
direction is this bruised in any way
all right did we get knocked by another
Universe passing through passing by
they're people who have looked they
haven't found any anomalous features in
the edge of our signatures so super cool
yeah yeah God
you just gotta love this stuff man what
the hell is wrong with people
pockets in that love this okay this is
Zach Stein he says hello this is Zach
I'm a first time caller oh Kentucky
first time caller yes okay well Tom
listener first time caller okay he says
how does scale pertain to the Multiverse
and quantum theory if the rules of
physics could change in a different
Universe could this be factored into
changes in scale we already see this in
quantum mechanics could the same thing
happen as we move up in scale in any
other direction okay so scale I I don't
know if I fully understand the question
but I can tell you this when we figured
out planets going around Stars we said
that's cool okay then we would later
learn about atoms that have electrons
and they say well we've been down that
road before we got planets going around
Stars electrons going around nucleus it
so is that is it that all the way down
is it that all the way up it's just
things orbiting other things turns out
no it's not it's very very different
that's why we don't say electrons
orbit do we say they move in orbitals we
borrowed the word and added an Al at the
end so electrons exist in orbitals not
orbits so it's not it's not scalable in
that sense you don't it's just not just
a big version of something little or
little version of something big plus
there are other issues right so chuck if
you had to scratch your head because you
got a head itch show me how you would do
that just do it okay there it is scratch
your head okay well you did that like
like a monkey does it you know
yeah that's not monkeys sticky finger I
thought I was being dainty okay
do you have lice just let me know
because that's what
uh so you have you have an itch in your
head and you responded within a fraction
of a second okay right if things just
scaled
and you were the size of a Galaxy
and just say just make it bigger if
you're the size of a Galaxy
and your head itched
you'd have to send the signal from your
head
to your finger to your brain to your
fingertip and then move your fingertip
to scratch your head
okay right
that can't happen any faster than the
speed of light
so the Galaxy's 100 000 light years
across
so the signal to get to your fingertip
and then come back and scratch your head
we take 200 000 years
to scratch your head right that's not
particularly helpful if you guys itch
yeah it's not very efficient right right
so so we're thinking big creatures that
if they existed itching is not a thing
okay so my point is things just don't
scale the way you might want them to
otherwise it would make for very easy
nesting doll Universe all the way down
and all the way up
so that being said it is possible for
other universes to have slightly
different laws of physics yes that is
possible and that would change
everything
and if you come upon such a universe do
not knock on its door
send in something else okay send in a
gerbil or something I don't know uh
nobody likes rats send in a rat and find
out what happens to the rat all right if
it collapses into a pile of goo or
explodes with his guts all over or it
um you know comes back with three
eyeballs you know I don't know depending
on the laws of physics many very many
things can be different
wow yeah well there you go and by the
way in the cosmic queries book
okay that's one of the installments of
the start talk book series in
collaboration with National Geographic
in that book there's an entire chapter
there's an entire chapter on how the
universe will die
and it has all the ways and it describes
how the Multiverse gives us all these
different combinations of size laws of
physics and and the like so it's a it's
a fun read so check it out
very cool yeah very cool
all right let's go to Renee skirt
Renee says hello
hypothetically speaking could you walk
on the rings of Saturn again
hypothetic
if you were to land on Jupiter or a gas
giant would you just fall straight to
the Core
can't wait to hear the answer thanks
Renee all right so here's what will
happen uh Santa's rings are not a thing
there's just like countless particles or
bidding Saturn okay so you can't take
your car and drive on the Saturn's rings
like it's a race track okay and it's not
a surface and all the gravity points
towards Jupiter so no you cannot walk on
set not even hypothetically can you walk
on Saturn's rings now not even
hypothetical not even hypothetically
sorry about that so disappointing so now
you want to land on Jupiter or Saturn
you get to the outer surface but it's
gaseous and you keep falling and you
keep falling and you keep falling until
you
and the surrounding gashes have the same
density
right then you'll just float up just
like you're in water
uh yeah yeah you find it you'll get to a
place under pressure
you'll just be buoyant there yeah boy
yeah yeah yeah when I uh a little bit of
scuba diving I've done that if you want
to get to a certain depth you have to
wear weird weights
exactly exactly just for that reason you
scuba dies before
oh yeah oh wow cool yeah I enjoy I enjoy
it immensely okay what's scuba stand for
oh God you would do this too
I know it's an acronym
[Music]
God no you got me man
crap I can't remember
self-contained underwater
breathing apparatus yes there you go
down go on it man got me okay got uh
just to just a tone uh what does laser
stand for
oh man I can't believe it
just trying to help I'm trying to give
you
okay
um light amplification Amplified
um stimulated emission
[Music]
wait what's the r
stimulated emission what's the r damn it
I'm losing my mind light amplification
by the stimulated emission of radiation
radiation okay I should have known that
all right you're over two you need one
out of here okay what is what does AM
stand for as uh in AM and PM am
um
am stands for staticky radio
okay so you win okay we'll let you out
of that one
oh
I'm trying to help you out here am and
p.m you know what AM stands for I don't
really know I'm I'm terrible you use it
every day I know I do okay so after
midnight and I don't know post morning I
don't know
uh maybe we'll do one with uh
abbreviations we'll do it we'll do it
explainer one day abbreviation we should
because I use all this stuff and here's
the problem I read these things you know
and then I just forget it's you know
okay because you never you never say
them no but plus you need plus you need
context to understand once I teach you
AM and PM you'll never forget it I
promise okay okay so we'll do it I'm not
gonna look it up and I don't do Google
know something yeah I don't do the whole
like let me run the Google I'm like okay
I gotta look it up and I gotta read it
yeah but like laser I've you know I'll
read that a million times and I still
won't remember okay and scuba when I
first scuba dived I had to of course
look up that's the first thing they make
you learn yeah yeah yeah yeah before
they before you ever put the tank on and
go into the pool which is where you
learn is the pool but yeah you gotta
learn so all right I'm interested for
amp and I'm not going to look it up Am
Pm there's am and FM XM XM radio okay
those all stand for things so all right
let's do it we'll do that explainer okay
that'll be fun that's a fun one so did
we did I finish answering that question
yeah you did because basically
the answer is no you can't walk on the
rings of Saturn and you'll sink until
you're born cannot fall to the center of
a gas giant you're gonna at some point
reach a place of buoyancy correct you
won't be stuck there and there is a
place we think Jupiter has a solid core
very far down
um or one of them but you'll be crushed
before you get what was it a solid chord
or a six yeah yeah you're long dead
before that happened you're long dead
before you ever all right is it a solid
there's a there's like an earth mass of
solid stuff in the center of Jupiter oh
yeah yeah oh I did not know that yeah
yeah okay yeah Jupiter is that big that
inside it's pregnant with a little Earth
yeah it's a tootsie Tootsie Roll uh
middle Tootsie Pop
last question one more real quick
all right here we go this is Bruce Ryan
Bruce Ryan says this what's up gents
Bruce Ryan here from Alexandria Virginia
Suppose there was a small black hole
with an event horizon the size of a
basketball floating in front of you what
would happen if you put your hand
through that event horizon would it suck
your entire body through or would you
just lose your hand or something
kind of wild in a way I like that
question yeah
[Music]
I don't know if he'll just bite off your
hand or if you'll fall into it what I do
know is that if you let go of it
okay by the way that that basketball
size black hole would have more mass
than the entire Earth so what would
really happen is you'll fall in you'll
just fall in okay because it's gravity
will just pull you away it's gravity
it's right it'll just you can't not fall
in it but because it has more gravity
than earth does if you let it go it and
Earth would fall towards each other and
Earth would lose it would eat the entire
Earth systematically
yes it'll break apart Earth and just
chew it and burst and that's it oh I'll
tell you right now this Earth
oh this Earth is delicious I don't know
who set out for Earth so I'm telling you
right now you need to call Uber Inc and
get some of this Earth
Saturn Saturn you have you had this
Earth
actually the black hole wouldn't have to
lick its fingers because it is all going
straight down the hole
it's just going straight down though no
face it's not even finger looking good
it's just it's like swallow good that's
what that is there you go well that's
all the time we got chuck oh man oh man
that was fun that was a lot of fun yeah
grab bag that was all right always good
to have you here right there this is uh
Star Talk Cosmic queries grab bag
Edition real the grass Tyson keep
looking up
foreign
[Music]